i've probably cleaned up close to three
or four hundred
different scenes where people have
disemboweled themselves put a knife in
their stomach and
and kept themselves open while they're
alive even one
gentleman uh decided to take some
scissors and cut his intestines
while he'd done it and throw them in the
bath
[Music]
so then how did you enter the cleaning
business so i started window cleaning
just as a lifestyle choice really um i
couldn't
a few hundred pounds a day and then work
a couple of days a week
and then um just do what i wanted to do
the other days
and um one of the ladies who i cleaned
her windows for
she asked me whether we would clean one
of her properties
where someone had been in for 10 years
and no one had been able to go and see
this person it was a warden assisted
flat
but it was so bad the state of it that
no one would go in
what way was it so when we opened the
door the floor was kind of moving with
fleas
um that was the first thing which we'd
not really encountered so
we had to deal with that um get some
specialist chemicals to deal with it and
then
i went into the bathroom one of the lads
who worked for me went into the kitchen
the bath i was dealing with was
completely full of feces right to the
top
and the toilet was as well and he was in
the kitchen
which was also in a terrible state the
third lad that was with us
threw up in his face mask um and nearly
choked so we had to rip his mask off and
he went and sat in the van
and then we carried on cleaning it and
um yeah so we kind of
got it all of that muck body fluid
10 years of groton grime cleaned it all
up and deodorized it
there's some people won't do it for
anything all the money in the world you
know there's people who are scared of
blood and scared of needles and
all that goes with it but most people
have got a threshold that as long as you
give them enough money for it they'll
they'll do it
how much did they pay you yeah so she
came in
um after we'd finished and she was like
overjoyed so we said
it's 2 000 pounds okay and she was like
yeah fine wrote us a check there and
then for it
and i was kind of 20 years old and just
thought i've earned two grand
less 300 quid to pay one of the lads so
1700 quid for a day's work
i'm not going to look back but to be
honest with you
i just saw pound signs instead of seeing
anything else i just saw so actually if
we can solve this problem
what can we charge and and that's how it
started we realized if we were going to
go to
local authorities police undertakers and
offer them our services that we'd have
to have something to
to kind of shore us up or to be
recognized that we knew what we were
doing
i went to a college in
in birmingham to learn how to clean
crime scenes
which was hilarious because it was just
a lady in a mini skirt in high heels
that poured some tomato sauce on a desk
we learned how to do that how to clean
that up
and walked away with the certificate
saying that we were crime scene cleaners
the first job that came in was about 10
miles from where i live
and it was a solicitor that asked for a
help
there was a property where a gentleman
had passed away and he'd been there for
eight weeks
and his dog had eaten his face in his
leg and we were faced with loads of
weird things that opened the door
initially in a swarm of blue bottles
flew past me and i had no idea whether
that would you know they would carry any
pathogen
um didn't know whether i should have
killed them before i let them out
um the smell was horrendous um and the
masks we had at the time
weren't very good but you could smell
this horrible
um decomposed odor and it's nothing like
dead animals
it was nothing like i'd been used to in
the past the gentleman had
i think had fallen off of a sofa
and died on the sofa or died on the
floor
and we could see this big black outline
so it's all black body fat
so the body kind of initially blows and
then bursts
and then all that fluid comes out so the
heavier the person
the more body fat that comes out the
person his body fat
decomposed through the wooden through
the carpet
into the wooden floor and then into the
concrete so it took me about three hours
to to get his body fat
out of the concrete and then we realized
that there was a shop
underneath so we went round the other
way and came in through the roadway
and it was a clothes shop and we said to
the lady who was running it did she know
that
she had any experience with bad smells
and she said i think there's a dead rat
in above the ceiling because maggots
keep falling in
to the changing rooms um and we were
like
really sorry it's not it's not a dead
rat someone's actually passed away up
there and then
she kind of screamed and she she didn't
realize what was going on and
so so that was a kind of a strange one
but it was great for us because we get
two places to clean up we got the shop
and the flat
so yeah it was all all a bit of a
learning curve but nothing like that
desk with a
tomato sauce on it at all
what does a decomposing body smell
the smell is a very strong ammonia smell
if you think of leaving a chicken breast
in a fridge that doesn't work for a few
weeks it's kind of that
but kind of times 10.
when i was in south america
a few years ago somebody kindly gave me
we're in a thai restaurant
gave me some rotting thai fish sauce
and it's the first time i've ever kind
of linked the smell with anything
horrendous when i've eaten something and
and that reminded me very much of of it
so that a decomposed
fish bizarrely was very similar to uh to
a decomposed body but
again not the same what's the most
disgusting thing
you've ever seen probably the worst
thing i've done
was um i had a phone call
from my local police authority to go to
a property where a gentleman had
died and he was a hoarder so
they opened the front door and it was
just like a tunnel there was a suitcase
in another suitcase
and that and everything was just boxes
so i kind of crawled in and went up and
got to a door
and i couldn't get through the doors i
came back and said i
i and i kind of naive to what was going
on a little um
and then they ended up breaking the
window so by this point it was about 80
people watching from this council estate
and as soon as they broke the window the
smell everybody just kind of ran
into their houses so the fire brigade
took the window out and
then all of the items that he'd
hoarded had fallen on top of him so we
had to uncover them for the scenes of
crimes officer to come and take a photo
of the body
um so that was not very often do we go
then the body is still there but with
this situation it was so we uncovered
everything
and um sadly i i moved a bag and the
gentleman's foot came off and
i had to put that back for them to take
a photograph
and then when we got down to the body
then the scenes of crimes officer could
come in and take a photograph
and bizarrely they had to have two
doctors come in to pronounce
that the person was actually dead um
even though they'd been there for eight
ten weeks
um and they decomposed they were on
about four or five mattresses that the
body was and it gone through about three
of them
so it was that was pretty horrendous um
from a visual
smell whole kind of situation in fact i
had two friends that were helping me we
were supposed to be going fishing that
day
and um and i had to put the fishing trip
off because
but this job came in and um so so both
my friends came with me so that we could
get it done quickly so we could go
fishing
and um they'd never seen anything like
it before one of the lads his wife is a
vegetarian
and it was the first time that she'd
cooked in meat
and she did did a maliga lamb and he got
home to this lego lamb and he said i
just can't eat it and it was just
i felt so sorry for what i kind of
impacted him with what's a normal
day in the life of a crime scene cleaner
for day to day you never know what's
going to happen when the phone rings
it could be something simple where
somebody is
taking an overdose and there's very
little to clean it could be where
somebody has
committed suicide and we've had some
horrific situations i've probably
cleaned up close to three or four
hundred different scenes
where people have disemboweled
themselves put a knife in their stomach
and kept themselves open while they're
alive even one
gentleman decided to take some scissors
and cut his intestines
while he'd done it and throw them in the
bath we've had situations where
people have killed themselves with a
shotgun in the conservatory
so their whole head has gone through a
polycarbonate roof
um all over the ceiling and all over the
the room
some are outside in piggeries and
dairies and
most farmers have got a shotgun so it
happens quite a lot on farms
we've had lots of other situations as
well where there's been crimes committed
where people have killed their partners
or people have
um have just murdered people to have to
go to a family home and clean up
after that kind of is really sensitive
and difficult
i've just wanted to make the place
better for people and when you know the
story
it gets quite sad sometimes
we very often come across suicide notes
that are left
and you can then grasp what's happened
some are kind of you know if a father
has lost custody of his son
and he's committed suicide then that has
an impact because i've got children and
i don't know how i would feel if that
happened to me one of the first ones
that kind of
got me um i don't know if it's
emotionally or or mentally really
but we went to bournemouth and a
chaptered bludgeon two professional
people
the gentleman had bludgeoned his wife to
death and it was so violent there was
literally blood everywhere
i mean you could open a drawer and there
was blood in in with the cutlery and
then if you looked underneath the drawer
there was blood underneath the drawer
it was even in the washing machine it
had gone through the washing machine
seal
in the lights on the lights everywhere
it was kind of this fine mist
and so you realize how violent it had
been but then the police officer told us
that the lady
had survived for three days on the floor
and then her neighbor found her
and she died on the way to hospital and
that was
kind of that was really sad that that
happened but also
i i'm married and i've had an argument
with my wife and
get to that point where you just walk
out and come back an hour later and say
sorry
but for someone to not do that and flip
and kill someone or take someone's life
that
kind of messed me up a bit you see so
much of
the darkness of humanity that leave a
lasting impact on how you think about
people
i suppose i would love to say that i i
i'm a real positive person i would love
to see the society is getting better and
better
and i know there's people out there who
really think that but they probably have
never
done what we do i've never seen such an
increase in drug abuse
you know since we started this 20 years
ago
we were maybe getting one needle pick
every two or three weeks now we get
five or six a day we get
loads of suicides loads of murders i
think suicide now is the biggest killer
of
men under the age of 30 which is a
horrific
situation people go to to colleges and
universities and they don't realize why
the windows only open four inches
it's because before they did that we
were going there cleaning up
loads of suicides where people jumped
out of buildings
it makes me want to be a better person i
think with my family and with my friends
and make sure that
i'm not sucked into that spiral i think
do you love the job yeah i do i do i i
get
incredibly bored incredibly quickly so
i even if i'm working on one
building for more than a couple of days
i can't cope with it i need to get out
and change my
my kind of surroundings and so this job
changes every single day
i love that about it i love i love that
we help families
i love that we help make things better i
love that we
undo problems for people but i really
really love
that i never know what we're going to be
doing the next day or what i'm going to
be dealing with
i knew when pe or something was going to
come up i knew that you know
the girls were going to start you know i
wasn't allowed to get changed with them
in their changing room or anything
because even though
like i say clitoris i say that loosely
my clitoris is basically like a small
dick